the special prosecutors investigation so
far has turned up no evidence of
collusion between Trump and Russia none
zero zilch nada but with every passing
day we learn more about the shocking
anti-trump bias of Bob Muller's team
Peter struck Jay Neary Andrew Weissman
the list keeps growing and growing and
just today we learned that attorney
Aaron Zeb Lee who's known as Muller's
right-hand man previously represented
the guy who helped set up Hilary's
private email system I can't even
believe this and who later destroyed two
of her mobile devices with a hammer I
wish we could put that hammer in the
Smithsonian would that be fun
the president's allies have had enough
and according to The Wall Street Journal
are now urging him to go on the offense
against a probe that now seems like
nothing but a partisan political lynch
mom if you asked me joining us now from
Phoenix is Republican congressman Andy
Biggs of Arizona and here in Washington
Democratic strategist Michelle jawanda
of the Center for American Progress
Michelle I want to start with you
because when you look at this list I
think we have a graphic of the
contributions that some and his team
have made James Quarles has given 30,000
50 dollars to Democrats Jeanne Reid 9150
Andrew Weissman 4,000 Greg Andres Andrew
goldstein
Elizabeth prologue or Britton van Greg
Rush Atkinson 200 bucks that's not a big
deal but all the other ones are not
insignificant and you add that the fact
that a lot of them represented one
represented the Clinton Foundation one
represented Ben Rhodes how does a
regular American person not look at this
Muller team as just a bunch of Trump
adversaries political adversaries who
want to undo a presidential election
well I think there are a few things when
we say in this country that you can
serve in law enforcement we don't have a
political test for those individuals I
come from a family of prosecutors when
you sign up and you say you want to
serve your country
there is no tests you don't have to
pledge allegiance to a president you
pledge it to this country and when
Robert Miller has found out about
individuals who he was concerned about
coffee
Tobias he fired them and that's exactly
what we want him to do so I understand
reveal it at the time when he got rid of
struck in July why didn't he reveal that
to the American public given the gravity
of this investigation right I mean I
think if we remember the purpose of this
investigation is national security so I
think what he is focusing on is how do
we keep this because I'm saying you
don't think that finding out you don't
think there's any illusion you don't
think there's any even appearance of a
conflict with this group of people
involved in an investigation that could
lead to the impeachment of a president
no appearance of a conflict not even an
actual conflict because if there's an
appearance of a conflict as a lawyer
you're really supposed to reveal what
your potential conflict could be and
they're to me the revelations are like
pulling tap pulling pulling teeth to try
to get this information no but don't we
want him to actually do what he did
which is to fire those individual I want
to know and I want to know what they've
said politically I want to know what
their emails TExES again to focus on
every individual as opposed to the
purpose of this against you know what
the fruit of the poisonous tree is of
course I ok so funny things right so if
you haven't you if you have ill-gotten
gains an investigation ill-gotten either
because of a bad actor or a biased actor
everything that comes as a result of
that could be called into question I
want to go to congressman Biggs on this
congressman I find the president's legal
team frankly to be a little bit kind of
almost gun-shy to question the Muller
team the president was very tough on the
Justice Department and has been in some
tweets but his legal team of there had
been more circumspect here yeah and I
think they're wrong to be circumspect
because what we have here this is the
very swamp creature that all of America
is looking at because it isn't that
Robert molar said oh hey this is why we
got rid of struck we had to pry that out
that came through FOIA requests Congress
has asked for information we're not
getting it one thing we found out from
director sessions and director ray or
attorney General Sessions the director
raised they don't even have a process
for vetting and for conflict of interest
so most most private sector law firms
and even and prosecutorial agencies if
you have a bias
you've got to disclose that bias because
it's an ethical
violation to take a conflict-of-interest
case so people check that out these
biases are not enough inconsequential if
you're giving $30,000 to Democrats guess
what you're all in you're all in if you
are being critical of President Trump
and in an overt wake showing up at
resist movement issues you're you're not
just saying hey I'm a political
participant in credibility I'm going to
ask you but yes does this not undermine
the credibility of an investigation when
you have rank partisans who worked for
Ben Rhodes who work for the Clinton
Foundation and now someone who actually
represented the guy who destroyed the
email this the devices with a hammer so
you're actually working for the
political adversary of the guy you're
now investigating now if that's not an
apparent conflict of interest then I
don't know what is but I think it
undermines the overall integrity of an
investigation that frankly should be
unassailable given the gravity of it
Michelle you can close out Laura I think
we need to remember that we're talking
about someone who served this country in
Vietnam he has had respect on both sides
of the aisle for years and if we are now
saying that someone who is as respected
as Robert Merlyn is a mistake of course
you can make a mistake but the question
is why are we raising these questions
now as he continued because we're
finding out the information of president
Trump's inner circle with the question
when Bill Clinton went after Bill
Clinton one a question is I'm gonna ask
okay yo Clinton went after ken starr's
legal team for being biased did you
criticize them for doing that when we
are focused on national security and
when we want to get to the root of what
roles no then I think where's the rush
of collusion man this is about
protecting one another where's the
Russian colonists it and going after
partisans he's interested in keeping
this country Russian polluted I think
it's actually there is mama call that
the FBI there's local venue I had
answers
men at the sei and now we are saying
that all of a sudden they're raging
liberals know that people on the
investigation almost like comical Lauren
okay so Andrew Weissman's are raging
look I think that raging cancer I think
it's almost comical know what's comical
is that you didn't criticize Bill
Clinton's people when they were trashing
ken starr as I recall I don't think
those guys were being criticized because
they were actually smart they went on
the offense against Ken Starr and that's
why in the end the Starr report ended up
the leading to impeachment but in the
end Bill Clinton ended up more popular
because last time I checked the gals in
the Senate ended up doing a pep rally
for Bill Clinton after that insecurity
isn't a part that's never been a
partisan issue congressman close it out
well look where nobody's criticizing
criticizing Muller's veterans history
we're criticizing the way he's
conducting this investigation which is
loading up the team it's like playing
basketball and not only is the other
team against you but all the refs the
scorekeeper and everyone else and that's
that's what you've got going on here and
that's the problem with Muller okay well